the problem is if you have the greatest
hammer and the greatest screwdriver and
the greatest wrench the greatest in
front of you if you don't use them
properly you will lose right people put
too much faith in the tools when I was
in film school mark that I did not want
to be a one-and-done
I not want to be a flash in the pan I
wanted to be here for the long haul rise
and shine it's an spresso time good
morning believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so grab your coffee and sip on
today's message be good at your craft
over to you Gary Vaynerchuk the problem
is if you have the greatest hammer and
the greatest screwdriver and the
greatest wrench the greatest in front of
you if you don't use them properly you
will lose right if there's a nail that I
have to put in that ground but I take
the wrench and I hit it when the hammer
was right there it still comes down to
the practitioner mm-hmm and you have to
be good at your craft and you have to
love your if you don't love sales if you
don't love it you have no chance because
it's so hard it's so painful there's so
much rejection right so those are the
things I think about
so technology's clearly enablers you've
just said there that the person is
equally important and more important
right and going back to you thank you I
just apologize for jumping in but let me
make it perfectly straight if I go play
Roger Federer right now in tennis and
I've the greatest tennis racquet ever
made like from taken from the Mars is
new like resources right and he took a
John McEnroe 1974 tennis racquet he
would whip my ass like I'm crushing
sales people that have every sales force
every one of your competitors 37
features upgraded went to every pro
conference watching this I will beat
their ass in sales every day of the week
right your talent people put too much
faith in the
fools it's not about the tools it's not
about the tools that you're using it's
not about the suit that you're wearing
it's not about the car that you're
driving it's about you at the end of the
day it comes down to you I was asked to
do a roundup of different entrepreneurs
of what your favorite tool was to help
you build your business and they asked
me and they asked 30 other people what
is the tool that you love most that
helps drive your business forward and I
was the only one who didn't want to give
a tool everybody listed their tools and
I was at the end of the day I was posted
at the very bottom the tools don't
matter stop blaming the tools and tools
are important don't get me wrong I love
using tools I think YouTube is a great
tool I think cameras are a great tool I
use tools every single day in my
business to help spread my message and
help my company grow but it's not the
reliance on the tools this is where I
think a lot of people fall down
I had an entrepreneur friend of mine
come to me he says what tools do we use
for your calendar how do you keep track
of your to dues because she had tried
using a notebook and using Evernote and
using OneNote
and using all sorts of different tools
using her phone everything and nothing
was working you know what the problem is
not the tools the problem is you write
the tools can help you go faster but if
you don't have the mindset if you don't
have the ambition if you don't have the
drive if you're not putting in the work
then the tools will never save you and I
think people have an over reliance on
the tools and that's my biggest problem
with it the tools can help you do that
last 20% but as 80% you it's 80% the
hustle in the hard work to get really
good at the thing and the tool can help
you go further I see tools as like
pouring gasoline on a fire you need to
have a spark you need to have a fire to
get something going and then the tool
the gasoline can help it explode but if
you just pour gasoline on wood nothing's
gonna happen I think the same thing
about suits and cars I think a lot of
people think you wear suit now you're
going to be successful suit doesn't mean
anything clothing is an expression of
self not a place where you get your self
worth somebody with no suit on could go
in and close a sale because they are who
they are they are confident they can
close that sale where somebody who's
only deriving confidence from their suit
will never win and so yes tools are
important but stop relying on the tools
get so darn good at the thing that
you're doing that
you cannot be ignored and then use the
tools to help you take it to the next
level now I have a special bonus clip
for you but before that I want to know
question of the day what are you
insanely good at leaving comes below I
want to find out what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love enjoy the
bonus clip and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
Apple and I we always used to think big
but we didn't think as big as we made it
our whole thing was how do we stay
traveling when you're in a ghetto or a
province you yearn to travel to see like
you'll one day I want to go to London
one day I want to go to Cambodia see the
ruins
well what's what do I have to do to be
able to travel over at my craft now is
writing songs and performing so you
master your craft to do something that
you wanted to do like how do I move my
mom out the projects how do I move my
entire family out the projects my uncles
cousins and nephew nieces so you master
your craft to be able to do that I came
to the the mindset when I was in film
school marked that I not want to be a
one-and-done I not want to be a flash in
the pan I wanted to be here for the long
haul
it wouldn't encourage south the great
affair qursaya what I'm doing is doing
press was one of his last times Ron his
journals asked him you wanted a greatest
master filmmakers of all time what else
you still have to learn and Kurosawa
said I still have a universe to learn so
I was in film school yeah and that blew
my mind
the baddest ever right he's 85 83 84 he
said he saw Sousa University to learn as
far as storytelling yeah that really hit
me like you know you really got a like
the Jazz term you got you got to stay in
the woods you guys you know and
constantly be honest perfecting your
crap and never get to the point that you
you trick yourself of thinking that you
know it all yeah
this is a life long journey you know
what distorts the to tell stories how
you craft them just be a good
storytelling and you do that by having a
body of work so it's always been on the
body of work yeah
what struck us most about Michael when
we met him all those years ago was his
dedication to the long hours in the pool
it's one reason why we trained seven
days a week while we train on Christmas
while training Thanksgiving 365 days a
year are many clubs that train seven
days a week so it gives you one extra
set training session every single week
where you can pick something up so I
mean I'm getting 52 more practices than
everybody else is and that's kind of
make that little or a big difference in
the end if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details